nous sommes le 25 mars 2015 nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction
bonsoir et bienvenue voici les
principaux titres de l'actualité
yvelinoise plus de 2500 postes à
pourvoir dans la police nationale lors
du Forum de la Cité des Métiers de
Saint-Quentin qui se tenait cet
après-midi nous y reviendrons le
socialiste Jean-Philippe Malek qui
pourrait perdre son siège de conseiller
départemental sur le canton de
saint-sirlécole avec son binôme Fabien
gelgon bilbaau il accuse près de 2500
voix de retard sur l'umpe celui qui fut
le suppléant de Benoît amamont à
l'Assemblée nationale sera en plateau et
puis avec unchef prévention nous
parlerons de la nouvelle édition du
Sidaction 3 jours pour favoriser la
recherche contre le sida et sensibiliser
le public et c'est à partir du 27 mars
la société d'informatique bullle
récemment acquise par Athos entend
regrouper ses différents C s en
île-de-fance ainsi c'est au clés
sous-bois que les salariés de Massie ici
les Moulineaux Saint-Ouin ou encore
sergis devrai travailler dans les
prochains mois une décision à l'origine
d'une mobilisation hier les syndicats
évoquant un plan social déguisé une
volonté de la direction de pousser à la
démission la direction qui annonce
poursuivre les négociations et qui
s'engage à proposer des mesures
d'accompagnement chaque mois un délégué
au recrutement de la police nationale
vient à la rencontre des cinquantinois
la Cité des Métiers à Quentin en Yveline
pour répondre à leurs interrogations à
propos de la profession actuellement
plus de 2500 postes à pourvoir de
l'adjoint de sécurité au commissaire la
police recrute de 18 à 25 ans sans
qualification à bac + 5 sur concours ou
sélection on a une autre voie d'accès
donc une une autre porte d'accès euh je
pourrais dire c'est euh pour les les les
personnes qui n'ont pas de pas beaucoup
de diplôme qui ont peu de diplôme ou pas
du tout de diplôme là on leur offre la
possibilité de
pouvoir la possibilité de passer un
concours interne mais surtout des
sélections qui leur offrent une
formation il y a beaucoup de métiers
dans la police
c'est assez méconnu puisque on se fait
on a des des a prioris sur la police on
connaît la police que l'on voit en
patrouille dans la rue euh dans les
villes euh ce qu'on ce que l'on sait
moins c'est que la métier que la police
offre un panel de de de missions de
métiers aussi différents les uns que les
autres euh très intéressant si je vous
dis il y a on peut trouver 200 métiers
dans la police je je n'exagère pas du
tout et cette année encore durant 3
jours à partir de vendredi l'opération s
d'action va mobiliser pour la recherche
contre le VIH à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline
l'association hchef Prévention a pris un
peu d'avance des dépistages rapides ét
proposé dès hier toute la journée une
minute pour savoir et éviter la
banalisation d'une infection qui touche
encore 6 à 7000 nouvelles personnes
chaque année en France yolen Tor et
Leine Raphaël est étudiant à
l'université il profite d'une courte
pause pour venir se faire dépister
auprès des bénévoles de l'association
évinoise à chef prévention un test d'une
minute précédé d'un entretien pour
savoir si les cro positif ou non vous
voyez combien de points un seul un seul
donc votreest votre test est négatif
ok maintenant je vais quand même vous
demander ce qui est important pour nous
de savoir quel est le dernier rapport
sexuel non protégé que vous avez eu
comme lui 200 à 400 étudiants sont venus
faire le test dans la journée la plupart
du temps par prévention j'ai changé de
partenaire et même si j'ai jamais fait
ça on n jamais trop à l'abri donc c'est
toujours mieux de d'assurer le coup
plutôt que se retrouver au final bah
avec le sida sans savoir bah là par
hasard aujourd'hui je suis passée devant
donc avec mes amis on s'est dit bah
pourquoi pas faire un test voilà les 27
28 et 29 mars prochain 3 jours pour
favoriser la recherche contre le sida le
Sidaction 2015 va tenter de collecter un
maximum de fonds à travers différentes
actions dans toute la France l'infection
ne doit pas être banalisée elle touche
encore 6 à 7000 nouvelles personnes
chaque année en France un fléo contre
lequel se bat achève prévention dans les
ivelines depuis de nombreuses années à
travers ces actions l'idée c'est de
réduire les risques que les gens
comprennent où est-ce qu'ils prennent
donc des risques sexuels et puis puisse
aussi avoir une réponse quant à leur
statut sérologique sur le sida alors les
étudiants c'est un cœur de CIP c'est une
population donc à risque on le sait tous
hein il y a pas mal de soirées il y a
pas mal aussi de conduites à risque hein
je pense à l'alcool mais notamment entre
autres mais pas seulement et c'est vrai
que pour le coup on a une vraie
nécessité à venir les dépister
régulièrement en l'occurrence sur 501 on
aimerait bien que ce soit un peu plus
que simplement une fois par an nous on
estime qu'il faudrait que ce soit deux à
trois fois par an pour effectivement
avoir une vraie action de prévention
l'association se déplace aussi dans les
centres commerciaux et les cœurs de cité
des ivelines sur l'ensemble de ces
actions 2 % des visiteurs se révèlent
séropositif c'est plus que dans un
centre de dépistage fixe qui n'en
détecte que 02 % dans l'année achef
prévention en profite aussi pour faire
connaître son application Tup pour
trouver un préservatif depuis son
lancement l'année dernière ce système
qui permet de géolocaliser préservatifs
et lieux de dépistage a été téléchargé
plus de 60000 fois sur les
smartphones le 27 mars va donc débuter
le S d'action l'association àchef
Prévention vous l'avez vu est toujours
très mobilisé pour parler des
différentes actions celles en cours et
celles à venir Yannick Mary bonsoir vous
êtes animateur de l'association o vous a
vu d'ailleurs dans ce reportage
l'association qui est dorénavant
installée dans les locaux de l'IPS à
trappe ce mardi l'équipe les équipes
d'chef prévention qui était donc dans
les locaux de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Eveline et c'est
important d'aller à la rencontre de ce
public que vous ne touchez pas
nécessairement en dehors de ces
opérations là pourquoi être allé à la
rencontre de ce public là justement
pourquoi au sein de l'université alors
en fait il faut savoir que les jeunes
donc déjà sont pas spécialement très
sensibilisés se rendent pas spécialement
des risques qu's en cour et comme le
disais dans le dans la vidéo mon
directeur il y a beaucoup de soirées il
y a beaucoup d'alcool il y a beaucoup de
tout ça et on pense pas spécialement
mettre un préservatif et il faut savoir
que la nouvelle contamination est très
hétérosexuelle
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut vraiment
mobiliser les gens et en leur faisant un
dépistage on leur fait aussi prendre une
prise de conscience et donc réaliser
qu'ils prennent des risques et du coup
essayer un petit peu de changer les
mentalités justement changer ses
mentalités c'est vraiment nécessaire
aujourd'hui il y a une banalisation sida
ne fait plus peur je je pense que qu'à
l'heure actuelle le sida n'est pas n'est
pas en enfin est sorti des meurs voilà
clairement c'est qu'il est plus dans la
tête des jeunes et on fait pas
spécialement attention
et et oui et malheureusement ça se
traduit dans les chiffres parce que
lorsqu'on entend les les résultats sur
des opérations comme celle-ci c'est
beaucoup plus élevé le le dépistage
positif que lors des points fixes
lorsque les les gens viennent vous voir
dans vos locau par exle il faut savoir
que dans un centre de dépistage ils sont
un taux de céropositivité de 0,2 %. h
nous qui allons vers les gens pour leur
faire leur dépistage pour les pousser à
se faire dépister on atteint des
résultats de 2 %. comment ça se passe
justement lorsqu'il y a la la détection
parce que là on a vu l'opération le
dépistage était fort heureusement pour
les les personnes lorsque nous étions
présents négatif mais lorsque ça s'avère
positif comment vous les accompagnez
alors nous on compte on les accompagne
jusqu'à la prise de leur traitement donc
on va leur annoncer leur
résultats on va leur faire prendre un
rendez-vous pour refaire tous les tests
et après pour vérifier il y a un
deuxième test pour vérifier le premier
résultat et une fois que le deuxième
test est également
positif le médecin qui leur a fait le
test leur préscrit une TR thérapie et du
coup après ils ont un suivi médical nous
on leur donne juste leur sérologie et on
les a accompagne au rendez-vous des
choses comme ça s'ils en ont besoin mais
après le SU psychique aussi
psychologique s ils veulent qu'on les
accomagne au rendez-vous chez le médecin
on le fait après le test si la personne
est positive elle veut aller boire un
café pour en discuter on va aller boire
un café avec elle pour en discuter il y
a aucun souci là il a un vrai échange
qui qui secé à ce moment-là lors des
dépistages qui sont organisés on
rappelle que c'est régulièrement que
vous parcourez le le département alors
ça c'est une des opérations qui est mené
c'était un petit peu avant le le site
d'action vous allez participer aussi
avecf prévention au site d'action il y
aura des collectes notamment collectes
de oui DS alors demain et vendredi
vendredi on sera à la gare de
Saint-Quentin de 17h à 19h et le midi on
va être dans l'université on a fait le
dépistage hier donc l'université
d'alenvert là aussi justement les les
gens se mobilisent encore le S d'action
ces opérations là vous arrivez à
collecter de l'argent ou ça reste
difficile quel l'cueil vous avez sur le
terrain alors en soit bon il y a
toujours le petit sourire qui qui permet
aussi de d'être beaucoup plus chaleureux
mais je pense que les gens surtout avec
l'action qu'on a fait hier quand on va à
l'université ont pris vraiment
conscience et je pense que les jeunes
n'hésiteront pas à mettre un petit
quelques euros qui peuvent servir à la
recherche et puis au développement
d'opération aussi comme l'application
tub ça a été évoqué dans le reportage
précédemment brièvement comment ça
fonctionne cette application ça sert à
quoi alors c'est une application en fait
qui marche sur smartphone téléchargeable
avec Apple Store et Android elle permet
de trouver des préservatifs en
géolocalisation et de trouver des
centres de dépistage DESS il aussi des
petits conseils pratiques sur comment
mettre un préservatif ce genre de chose
et aussi euh des petites autres petits
conseils genre qu'est-ce qu'un test
postexoition ou des choses comme ça qui
permettent d'ussi d'avoir des
renseignements et de la formation c'est
de la documentation et ça fonctionne
grâce à l'application vous voyez la
petite bande annonce qui revient sur
cette cette application tub qui est
téléchargeable Tup c'est très simple
pour avoir les les renseignements et
géolocaliser les les distributeurs de
préservatif notamment on a l'impression
lorsqu'on vous écoute que il faut
reprendre tout le travail presque à zéro
aujourd'hui c'est le sentiment vous vous
avez il faut refaire de la pédagogie
réexpliquer rappeler l'importance du
préservatif la dangerosité de la maladie
de l'infection alors en
soit les gens savent qu'il faut se
protéger les gens savent qu'il y a des
risques mais h non non un petit peu rien
à faire c'est que en soit on se dis
c'est les autres et ça nous arrive
jamais et je pense que quand enfin moi
je me rends compte qui suis en train de
dépister les gens dans les barnomes je
vois quand ils attendent le résultat ils
ont vraiment peur ils ont des doutes et
quand ils ressortent et qu'on les revoit
plus tard nous disent c'est vrai que
maintenant on fait beaucoup plus
attention parce qu'il y a une prise de
conscience et tant qu'on est pas mis
devant le fait accompli on se rend pas
compte de la dangerosité de de nos actes
parce que on va encore le rappeler mais
on ne guérit pas du sida il y a un
accompagnement un traitement et ça reste
très lourd c'est quelque chose à vie h
on la trithérapie c'est quelque chose
qui nous suit jusqu'à la fin après les
charges virales peuvent être
indétectables mais elles n'ont pas
encore atteint 100 % donc non non c'est
la nécessité la seule et unique solution
c'est de se protéger bien sûr
l'importance du préservatif on le
rappelle toujours à l'occasion du
saction mais c'est tout au long de
l'année merci Yan Mar d'être venu en
plateau les locaux d'chef prévention
installés dans les locaux de l'IPS
attrape dorenavant merci encore le S
d'action 2015 qui va donc débuter depuis
21 ans 311 millions d'euros ont été
reversés par s d'action pour aider la
recherche et améliorer l'accès aux soins
la prévention et l'aide aux malades
autre sujet la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de versaill 550 ans neline
qui va déjà souffler ses 10 bougies
inaugurées en 95 par sa présidente de
l'époque Sylvie fauchux président de la
Région Jean-Paul Huchon vous envoyez les
images d'archives elle aur a coûté 17
millions d'euros pour 7500 m² 1100
places assises on encore un auditorium
de 70 places ce sont bien sûr les images
avant la réalisation du site une soirée
de commémoration qui est prévue demain
avec une exposition au photos sur cette
construction rappelons qu'une fondation
a été lancée récemment afin de collecter
des fonds pour assurer sa pérénité la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de 50 ans en
Yveline et qui ouvre ses portes un peu
plus de 65 heur par mois dans le cadre
de la la journée des métiers du
spectacle vivant organisé par la Cité
des Métiers c'est l'école des tris is
qui ouvrait ses portes à 50 ans neline
attrape plus précisément pour faire
découvrir les nouvelles formations
proposées Mélanie poet et William
lsieur peut connaître la formation des
régisseurs technicien son et technicien
lumière c'est le but de cette journée
spéciale spectacle vivant organisé par
la Cité des Métiers de Saint-Quentin en
iveline c'était pour être sûr de savoir
si je voulais bien rentrer dans cette
école V que j'avais déjà fait je suis
déjà venu aux portes ouvertes il y a 3
ans et ça m'avait déjà plu mais là
c'était pour savoir si avec le mon bac
pro vente qui n'est pas du tout en
rapport si je pouvais y rentrer au menu
du jour visite des locaux de l'école
institut international de l'image et du
son des lancours souvent on a
des des jeunes qui viennent chercher
évidemment de l'information mais qui ont
déjà pour la plupart d'entre eux un un
pied dedans dans le cadre du loisir ou
du bénévola ou ou parce que ils ont des
membres de leur famille ou des amis de
la famille qui sont immergés dans dans
ces métierslà au 3IS la formation de
technicien s'effectue en 2 ans celle de
régisseur se fait sur 3
années invité et politique à présent
dans ce journal Jean-Philippe Malet
bonsoir vous êtes le conseiller général
sortant sur le canton de saint-sire
l'école candidat pour un nouveau mandat
avec un binôme cette fois-ci c'est la
nouvelle règle au côté de Fabienne
gelgon bilbaau vous êtes arrivé second
derrière la liste de l'Union de la
Droite dimanche on va voir d'ailleurs
les différents résultats s'afficher le
duo Philippe benasaya Sony abro avec
39,18 % suivi de Fabienne gelgon bilbaau
et Jean-Philippe my avec 24,40 % et puis
le FN le Front national Julien grim et
perine genunot les voilà ses résultats
donc pour le Front national avec
19,89 % je précise que nous avions
convié pour un débat la liste de droite
qualifié mais aucun de ces représentants
n'était disponible Jean-Philippe my
votre est-ce que vous le vivez comme une
déception aujourd'hui euh écoutez je
suis mitigé à la fois soulagé soulagé
parce que rappelez-vous durant 3
semaines tous les sondages nationaux
placai le Parti socialiste et ses
candidats en 3e position à 19 % des
suffrages exprimés c'est arrivé dans
certains cantons he pour préciser le
Fond national qui est arrivé second dans
l canton du du département tout mêmeûr
bien sûr et beaucoup de candidats
socialistes ont été battus dès le
premier tour quand on est en 3e position
et qu'on ne fait pas 12,5 % des inscrits
on n'est pas qualifié pour le 2è tour
bien donc je je suis qualifié pour ce
deième tour mais évidemment je vois bien
que que je suis assez loin et donc on
pendant toute cette semaine on mobilise
on se bat pour pour rassembler pour
assembler les électeurs de gauche et
au-delà des électeurs de gauche les
ivelinois est-ce que pour revenir un
petit peu sur le le détail de ce
résultat sur votre commune la commune de
boisarciie vous étiez aaravant au sein
de ce conseil municipal vous êtes à 24,6
% 41,9 % pour l'UMP l'p qui a remporté
au derniers municipal hein cette cette
commune la campagne n'a pas fonctionné
même dans un territoire que que vous
avez avez bien connu que vous connaissez
bien cel de boisarcy la difficulté mais
au-delà de de la ville de boisarcy hein
c'est que les électeurs de de gauche ne
sont pas all les voter alors c'est un
phénomène assez assez classique
malheureusement que lors des élections
ce qu' l'on appelle intermédiaire hein
en général la majorité présidentielle et
parlementaire et souvent souvent on va
dire désavoué dans tous les cas essuie
essuie des défaites bon je le regrette
moi pour moi l'enjeu maintenant c'est de
de dire aux électeurs de gauche aux
ivelinois que il peut n avoir dans
l'assemblée départementale que des élus
de droite
UMP il me semble important que de faire
vivre le pluralisme politique d'exercer
un contrôle démocratique de faire
entendre une autre voix que simplement
uniquement des des voix d'élus UMP je
trouve ça un petit peu peu pas dangereux
mais pas très pas très bon pour pour la
démocratie locale pour vous le résultat
qui s'est exprimé dimanche on verra si
dimanche prochain ça ça se confirme
c'est l'impact c'est l'écho du du
National du du mauvais aurat du
gouvernement aujourd'hui ou est-ce que
c'est aussi une sanction de de l'action
que vous vous avez mené en tant que
conseiller départemental écoutez il y a
peut-être de de de tout hein moi je
chacun a ses responsabilités le
gouvernement le Conseil général sortant
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
évidemment je je pourrais si vous voulez
pendant 1 heure vous dire tous les
points de désaccord que je peux avoir
avec le avec le gouvernement je rappelle
souent exprimé d'ailleurs sur cette
lorsque j'étais député il y a plusieurs
projets de loi que je n'ai pas voté hein
je n'ai pas voté par exemple traité
budgétaire européen bien mais vous savez
faire de la politique c'est aussi gérer
des contradictions c'est gérer la
complexité des choses et un certain
moment il faut bien voir que bah il faut
se rassembler il faut que les électeurs
de gauche se se rassemble pour porter
dans l'assemblée départementale au moins
un élu de de gauche je rappelle
j'insiste il peut demain il n'y avoir
que des élus de droite à l'assemblée
départementale est-ce que c'est simple
pour la démocratie je ne le pense pas la
droite qui est en effet arrivée en tête
du scrutin dans les 21 cantons il y a
pas de triangulaire mais des deuxiè
tours entre le PS ou le Front national
dans 8 cantons sur les 21 vous avez
réservoir de voix plutôt mince environ
12 % Europe Écologie les vers Front de
Gauche c'est ce qu' a fait l'autre liste
de gauche qui se présente sur ce canton
de saint-cir l'école et encore
aujourd'hui il n'appelle pas clairement
à voter pour vous mais à faire barrage à
la droite il y a une petite nuance tout
de même oui tout à fait mais ça vous
savez mais d'ailleurs dans d'autres
canton hein c'est là aussi c'est une
problématique générale nous constatons
que le Front de Gauche Europe Écologie
Les Verts pas tous mais enfin une partie
ne pratique pas ce qui a été une grande
tradition républicaine qui est le
désistement républicain je considère que
ces responsables politiques ne sont pas
la hauteur des de nos
concitoyens forme
d'irresponsabilité de populisme je
rappelle que le Front de Gauche
l'extrême
gauche depuis plusieurs années ne gagne
pas d'élections et non seulement ne
gagne pas d'élection mais ne se qualifie
pas pour le deuxème tour donc ne pas
appeler au rassemblement des forces de
gauche je trouve que c'est une attitude
qui est vraiment peu responsable mais
vous savez nul n'est propriétaire de son
électorat et les électeurs de gauche ont
ont beaucoup plus de de bon sens et
d'intelligence politique que que les
dirigeants de ces finalement de ces
appareils qui euh qui sont moribond qui
sont tout à fait vermoulus donc la
problématique vous êtes sévère avec les
votre votre ancienne majorité de gauche
hein parce qu'on va tout même rappeler
que vous étiez des alliés par le passé
hein euh là aujourd'hui il y a cette
problématique de l'abstention il y a la
problématique du Front national aussi
presque 20 % dans le canton oui c'est
beaucoup oui c'est beaucoup bien sûr le
Front national le Front National est à
un niveau un niveau très élevé mais ça
il ne suffit pas de dire que que les
voilà que c'est pas bien de voter Front
national he il faut aussi que vous le
dites quoi à ces électeurs qui au second
tour ne pourront pas voter Front
national est-ce qu'ils peuvent se
retrouver dans votre programme est-ce
que c'est des électeurs vous allez aller
chercher sur le terrain aussi est-ce que
vous vous adressez plutôt aux
abstentionnistes al moi je je je
m'adresse d'abord
euh aux électeurs de gauche aux
abstentionnistes finalement je je
m'adresse à tout le monde aux ivelinois
et on leur demandait de en leur
demandant de bien regarder quelle a été
mon attitude politique lorsque j'étais
député voilà lorsque j'étais député j'ai
j'ai résisté à à ce qui m'a semblé être
par moment des des projets de loi des
sens libérales j'ai résisté à une à une
forme de déréglementation de
libéralisation donc moi j'appelle
les voilà les ivelinois à à bien
regarder quelles sont mes positions
politique évidemment de gauche hein je
suis soutenu par le le PS et le MRC mais
j'ai par exemple voyez j'ai j'ai
vraiment tenu à ce que le mouvement de
Jean-Pierre chevenem euh me soutienne
hein avec des positions qui sont
toujours toujours très intéressantes
justement sur vos propositions sur celle
que vous portez pendant cette entre deux
tours ça n'a pas changé du premier tour
j'imagine et quel quels sont les points
forts qui se dégagent et on va une fois
de plus rappeler que les compétences des
conseils départementaux ne sont pas
clairement établies c'est encore en
discussion par les différents
parlementaires entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée il y a encore plusieurs
navettes pour définir tout ça mais on
peut imaginer que ça restera autour du
social des compétences des collèges
également donc aujourd'hui quelles sont
les propositions concrète que vous
faites que vous allez porter au conseil
départemental si vous êtes élu alors
nous on souhaite que vraiment le Conseil
Général continue moi j'ai porté des
délibérations lorsque que j'étais
conseiller général sur la tangentiale
ouest qui impacte non seulement le
département des ivelines mais
particulièrement ce territoire je
rappelle sir à Saint-Germain tout à fait
dans un premier temps et ensuite RC Ra
et ensuite her donc vous voyez c'est
quelque chose de de très
important que vraiment j'ai porté des
délibérations on étai présenté en
assemblée emental par par moi-même donc
ça c'est un un projet de longue haline
quoi hein mais également on souhaite
deuxième chose un petit peu structurante
je souhaite que le Conseil général
s'engage pleinement dans la déclinaison
vous savez de la conférence sur le
réchauffement climatique climatique
pardon qui aura lieu au Bourget à la fin
de l'année les collectivités
territoriales vont être appelé par
l'État pour justement mettre en place
des des mesur hein pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique la dimension
environnementale aujourd'hui la
transition énergétique le développement
durable tout ça c'est extrêmement
important donc moi j'insiste pour que le
le Conseil Général des ivelines prenne
toutes sa part dans cette politique mais
aussi prennent sa part dans la politique
de de logement au côté des autres
départements et de la région île--france
avec l'État pour construire plus et
mieux de logement je fais les
propositions des propositions dans dans
ce sens et puis pour les collèges
puisque visiblement les collèges
resteraient de la compétence du
Département nous demandons à ce que dans
les collèges de la même façon que les
communes pratiquent le ccient familial
vous savez dans les cantines euh pour
des écoles élémentaires et bien le
Conseil général met en place d'abord une
harmonisation des tarifs dans les
collèges et puis des ctients des ccients
familiaux dans les cantines des des
collèges voilà quelquesunes des
propositions beaucoup plus nombreuses
que que nous faisons et et pour revenir
sur une des propositions justement vous
avez évoqué l'aspect environnemental là
vous vous adressez clairement aux
écologistes aux électeurs d'urope
écologie les ver ah bien sûr mais vous
savez moi je fais tout à fait la
différence une fois de plus vraiment
entre les électeurs et et et et les
dirigeants de ces de ces de ces
appareils politiques qui qui franchement
par moment ne sont ne sont pas
responsables quoi hein parce que quand
on est à Europe écolog Gil les vert ou
au Front de Gauche ne pas faire la
différence entre l'UMP le parti
socialiste je laisse juge les électeurs
de gauche de cette de cette appréciation
une dernière question vous êtes le
conseiller départemental sortant vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure l' a la
possibilité de faire le grand chlem et
vous dites que c'est important qu'il a
encore des des élus d'opposition comment
dans l'opposition vous qui êtes sortant
et vous étiez déjà dans l'opposition on
peut se faire entendre est-ce qu'on peut
porter des propositions est-ce que ça
sert à quelque chose mais vous voyez par
exemple hein toujours dans cette
problématique de la gauche du Front de
gauche et Europe Écologie Les Verts qui
ne veut pas appeler à voter clairement
pour les candidats socialistes moi
j'aiappelle à faire barrage à la droite
tout est dans je n'ai qu'une chose à
dire c'est qu'il y avait dans la
dernière mandature au conseil général
nous étions neuf élus de gauche se
socialistes un Europe Écologie Les vert
un communiste h et bien nous avons fait
un seul groupe politique pour unir nos
forces et nous avons travaillé ensemble
en très bonne harmonie euh de façon de
façon euh vraiment euh harmonieuse euh
et euh et et sans aucune difficulté donc
nous travaillons ensemble voilà donc
j'appelle les électeurs de gauche à à à
prendre acte du fait que lorsque nous
étions dans dans l'opposition dans la
dernière mandature nous avons travaillé
ensemble les socialistes euh il était de
fa même même dans l'opposition oui d'une
certaine façon mais il faut s'engager
hein moi je je vous l'ai dit sur la
Tangentielle ouest euh j'ai porté les
délibérations je me suis engagé merci
Jean-Philippe met candidat socialiste
sur le canton de saint-cer l'école avec
votre binôme Fabien gelgon bilbaau
opposé à Philippe benasaya et Sonia Bro
pour l'Union de la Droite dans le cadre
du 2ème tour dimanche et n'oubliez pas
que dès 19h45 sur TVfil nous vous
proposons une soirée spéciale pour
suivre tous les résultats en direct en
simultanée sur Radio sensation merci à
vous et puis si vous résidez sur trappé
encs encore la derrière n'oubliez pas
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez voir grâce
au replay sur notre site internet le
débat entre les candidats Jean-Michel
Fourgous UMP Jeanine marie à divers
gauche ballotage favorable pour le
binôme de droite sur ce secteur Valérie
PCR qui sera d'ailleurs ce soir en mriie
deslencour pour un meeting de soutien et
vendredi c'est l'ancien Ministre Benoît
mon mon député PS qui sera lui au côté
des candidats de gauche à la salle
Jean-Baptiste Clément à trrappe le
journal revient demain jeudi au mêmes
horaires pour un nouveau point sur
l'actualité locale très belle
soirée